[Music]
my name is Jamie Barrow and I'm
Britain's fastest snowboarder we're here
in the beautiful Beijing on the Great
Wall of China and tomorrow thanks to
tours we have been given special
permission to film and Snowboard within
the most secretive country in the world
North
Korea I'm always looking for exciting
new projects and when I found out there
is a ski resort in North Korea I
couldn't miss the
opportunity it was nice to meet a
mixture of tourists who were going and
we were excited to find out why they
chose North Korea out of anywhere in the
world not many people really know about
the country which is one of the main
reasons I want to go I'm looking forward
to just seeing firsthand what the
country is really about and getting to
know the people the culture I live a
very structured life and I just had of
like impulsive okay I want to do
something crazy now maybe the biggest uh
biggest thing is is the question you
don't know what's here like you you get
a picture through Western media which
might or might not be very SK despite
many people advising us not to go and
they been a missile test just days
before we headed into pongyang when we
landed we met up with two guides and
Driver who would be watching over us for
the
week our first stop was the great bronze
mansu day statues where we were told to
lay flowers to show our respects to the
leaders finally got on Valentine's Day
it might not be for the right
[Music]
reason we arrived at the hotel late that
night it was isolated on an island away
from the city and we were forbidden from
leaving
unattended there was a revolving
restaurant a casino that wasn't open a
swimming pool an even a bowling
Alle oh
[Music]
good roast
flatfish fried chicken with
breadcrumbs and vegetable sat for
breakfast under the watchful eye of our
tour guides we were whisk around the
city to see all the sites more great
statues and marble monuments pay tribute
to the leaders and serve as a reminder
of the Korean War and a country divided
in
two traveling around the city we looked
for a glimpse of what everyday life is
like in
pongyang our guides were always watching
us making sure we would only film what
they wanted us to see from the medas you
see like empty streets and everything
being uh staged for a tour is very
scripted but being here it's it's
obviously not the whole truth many of
the places we visited the streets were
empty but preparations were being made
for the leader's birthday and we were
taken to see some traditional Mass
dancing someone said like when we come
here they think that we are the devil
and we think that they are robots right
it turns out that neither of us are
right you you do get to see what nor
greens do and how they live their life
and he meet people and it's uh it's been
surprising 180 km south of Pyongyang is
the demilitarize Zone the most heavily
militarized Border in the
world they were proud to show us all the
American planes tanks and helicopters
that were captured in the Korean War
okay yeah that that would not have been
good being in
[Music]
there they were particularly proud of
the USS Pueblo an American spy ship that
caused an international incident when it
was attacked and captured by North Korea
in
1968 looks more comfortable than the our
bed in the hotel
[Music]
actually
I'm trying to keep an open mind for it
all it's a
bit yeah I don't know how to describe it
what's more weird is that literally no
one is around we're the only ones in the
whole
[Music]
museum after an exhausting few days in
Pyongyang it was Kim jong-il's birthday
and we were treated to the biggest
fireworks display we had ever
seen
[Music]
today we're heading up to the m ski
resort had a good few days in Pyongyang
and uh really looking for a good few
days riding on the
mountain that was just m blown by The
Resort this amazing hotel at the end of
a 4-Hour bumpy ride pops out of
[Music]
nothing we made it to the mass ski
resort it's a bit crazy to actually be
here I'm smiling a lot more now excited
it's a few days in the city and now
we're finally in the mountains it's good
and Kim's looking forward to it as
[Music]
well we checked in and set off to
explore the hotel it was the first time
we were allowed out on our own without
our tour gues there's not one person
coming down the big slopes those some
nice steep slopes we go get some speed
on
that so we're going to go downstairs
into the basement where all the
excitement of the hotel
happens North Korean haircut oh here we
go here are the different North Korean
haircuts you can
get
[Music]
how much $1 because these are
coupons what
she no don't
laugh but that was fun I want have
J it feels a little weird to be
perfectly honest um but it is beautiful
not in line with much other stuff that
we see except maybe Mausoleum there's
always someone helping you and they're
catering you so this is the uh room
where Rod
[Music]
St
is that one
snake two
[Music]
[Applause]
Snak
[Music]
for
as our guides have been so kind in
pointing Us in the right direction we
thought it would only be right to return
the favor
B St
B
okay there you go that's it hold that
toes
up it's
good it's okay I'm here don't worry okay
you going to point forward again you
ready keep going keep going keep going
good good good good good
good hold on
hands you getting hang of there and they
look see the smile on their face as well
it's quite nice good good good point
where you going good good
[Music]
good
yeah good she said uh this is better
than skiing this is what we're trying to
get
[Music]
going
good very good she's crazy
she's like no I want to go from here I
want to go higher I want to go
faster isn't this this is awesome well
[Music]
done we're going up to the first run it
seems like everyone's down on the
beginner slopes and intermediate slopes
so the slopes from they top there's not
one person coming down so it's
completely free for
us you have to keep pinching yourself
realizing where
where you are we're in North gr going
[Music]
[Applause]
snowboarding
[Music]
oh
it's our last day in the dpk and you
never get this fresh powder day sunny
sky and absolutely no one else on the
slopes I still don't know what it is I
don't know what's going on here I mean
obviously there's the the politics and
there's the people and there separate
things most everything I came in with
has sort of been tossed out or rethought
I'm not really sure how to put it to
words but uh I have do have a completely
different view of uh of this country for
sure there are some places we may never
truly understand and we can only show to
you what was shown to us a small piece
of a much bigger picture nonetheless the
opportunity to glance inside the most
secretive country in the world gave us a
few more answers and a lot more
questions than we started out
[Music]
with